you lost I think your your best friend
in the world Don Rickles not too long
ago and we have a conversation about
that and I was curious I know that you
guys were best friends but you guys have
such such different energies I mean
Rickles appear you down here and I'm
it's a very different comedic energy and
wondering how you became friends how did
that friendship work well we was in
Vegas and my wife Ginny and I were
married
Ginny new Don's wife Barbara Rickles
Barbara's Clara at that time so Don was
in town Dona Barbara were in town at the
Sahara in the lounge that was in the
lungs and I was in the main room at the
Desert Inn which I always like to remind
him that I was in the main room so that
jenni said we've got to get together
with Barbara and Don because I've never
met Don before I knew what he did
according but so he goes on at like 2:00
in the morning that's his first show so
we went and we went to the coffee shop
and we sat there and Ginny was talking
to her done I was talking to Barbara and
now it's time to go in for Don's 4:00
o'clock show he 4 o'clock in the morning
so we're walking in and Jenny said to me
she said he is the sweetest man he just
he's just such a dear man and he he oh
he's on the road a lot he the mindy his
daughter was just born and he wants to
be home and i said well honey he's a
lovely man but his act is a is a little
different then then maybe you just saw
mm-hmm so we go in and they put us right
in the front row in the end i'm this air
and the
and so Don comes out the first thing he
says he said the stammering idiot from
Chicago is in the audience with his
hooker wife from Bayonne good wake-up
call for her yeah please fell like yeah
yeah yeah I tried to tell you tried to
tell you